now wind farms are potentially killing
tens of thousands of bats a year even
though risk assessments were carried out
to prevent deaths certainly on that
scale a survey of 29 wind farms showed
that 194 bats a month were killed
extrapolate that across the country it
could mean that across the the whole of
Britain's onshore wind farms around
80,000 80,000 bats are killed each year
by our wind turbines or joining us now
Leo Murray the director of the strategy
of director of strategy at 10-10 that's
a climate change awareness charity and
Leah Gilmore who's a researcher in bat
ecology at the University of Bristol
welcome both Lear if I can start with
you you're you're at Bristol University
I think this research comes from Exeter
and what they did but obviously we knew
that there was a danger posed by wind
turbines to bats but not on this scale
and the academics have used sniffer dogs
haven't they had at Exeter to try and
actually find the corpses of these bats
particularly the pipistrelle yes yes so
we can go for quite a while the turbines
pose a significant threat to a lot of
wildlife including bats but this is this
is the first sort of study that's shown
that this the the scale of this this
effect in the UK so with there's been
some studies in the states and also
mainland Europe but this is the first
time that we've actually seen what's
happening here in the UK so it's
interesting to see the numbers and so
it's not all turbines necessarily but
definitely a lot of the turbines that
they looked at in this Exeter study yes
yeah I mean the only of the obvious
question exposes you know we think of
bats we think of the sonar they used to
accurate an avid so swiftly and so
deftly a suggestion it doesn't work at
high altitude and that's why they're
they're hitting the blades no not
necessarily the reason that bats are
being killed wind turbines is is largely
suggested to be too due to them being
attracted to the turbines actually to
feed on insects that may be swarming
around there or caught in the vortices
of the blade so it's not actually known
exactly no one's tested it but it's Jay
so that it's more to do with the fact
that they're attracted rather than their
education failing or chance collisions
leo would you make of this number up to
up to 80,000 bats a year being killed by
wind turbines yes so I think I'm the
first thing the first thing to say about
that is that I spoke with the lead
author of the the Exeter study yesterday
and he was quick to distance himself
from that eighty thousand deaths figure
he told me that his team could not work
out how the Telegraph had calculated
eighty thousand deaths you know one of
the key findings of the study is that
bat that's extremely variable at
different wind farm sites so how the
Telegraph calculated a cigar to give us
that we'd like to know we would like to
know i'm not i'm not a bat scientist I'm
unlike Leah and but look I think the key
thing to take away from this study is
that we need to do more to protect bats
you know this is not a reason to stop it
right a bit late now they've built the
wind farms haven't we yes so I think
come in yeah Bailey only only a Leah
works on solutions say yes so the
difficulties with this is that the
current mitigation measures that are put
in place at the moment to protect bats
are just not up to scratch they're not
they're not working so are the
mitigation measures need to be put in
place and we do need to do more to
protect bats but also you know at wind
turbines that are already in place so
post-construction so I think there needs
to be a shake-up of the environmental
impact assessments which is suggested in
the in the X to study but also post
post-construction mitigation measures
need to be put in place as well for
those already post instruction
mitigation measures turning them off in
the summer is that what you mean in
plain English not necessarily so you you
can look at predicting but fatalities
using weather conditions and that's been
done in mainland Europe and then you can
turn off or you know a limit the
operation of the turbines at different
times there's also options for other
mitigation measures such as deterrence
which could be used at turbines and they
would keep the bats away from the
turbine blades so things like
acoustic deterrence speakers that give
out a sort of white noise sound so it'll
really work mirror are we sure they are
we sure they'd work well that's what my
research is on so I'm looking at that at
the moment so and sort of some
preliminary studies are saying that I've
done which I can't sort of comment too
much on but saying that we can show that
maybe these acoustic terrance may have
some effect at keeping the bats away but
nothing's been done at turbines just yet
in the UK leo just go back to what the
Telegraph wrote up I mean clearly
there's it's often the case that shrewd
journalists you use those conditional
words like could and up to to frame an
argument in a certain way but I think
it's a reasonable assumption isn't it
that thousands of bats may be going to
disagree with me that thousands of bats
are being killed by wind turbines every
year is that a price worth paying for
renewable energy well I think it's
important to get some perspective here
because for a start climate change
represents a much bigger threat to bat
ultimately than wind turbines do right
and you know if we fail to reduce
emissions fast enough to prevent the
worst case scenarios on the climate
change from happening many bat species
will be driven to extinction and nobody
is saying that our wind turbines are
going to make any bat species go extinct
so I think that's the first thing to say
secondly they have been other studies
which compare the rates of death for
birds and bats and from different energy
generation technologies and you know
2009 study showed that fossil plant
generation ultimately results in the
best of roughly 15 times as many bats
and birds as wind turbines do there's
just a relentless focus on the direct
impacts of wind you know ultimately all
energy so there's no such thing as a
free lunch right all energy sources have
some environmental impacts and the
environmental impacts of wind turbines
are very very small compared with those
technologies that they are replacing so
you know ultimately we have we have a
net gain from switching to win
generation from things like burning coal
the thing is Leo I mean for instance I
can recall within the last couple of
years we did a story about the
protection afforded to our bat
population particularly in relation for
instance
to the churches belfries where they were
roosting and they couldn't be moved on
because of these regulations such that
they were for instance their droppings
were falling on the heads of
parishioners during weddings such as a
degree of protection under law that they
enjoyed and some people see a gap
between that kind of protection and
what's happening at the wind turbines
you seems to jail actually that God well
that would be a misleading perception
because then you know I think as Leah
pointed out and as the study you know
one of the key find is that this study
is that enormous sums of money are spent
and in pre-construction environmental
impact assessments and and the what the
study is found is that those don't
necessarily work very well they don't
work very well to predict the number of
bad debts so we need a different
mitigation measure it's not as if the
protections aren't there there there
there just not working so you know this
is why the work of people like Leah at
bristol on them on you know ultrasound
transmitters but the potential of
different mitigation measures is so
important and as I say bats ultimately
benefit from our switching to renewable
generation sources and you buy that
argument that I mean Leo is suggesting
that it's you know bats need to think
long term about this yes I completely
agree i think that climate change is a
major threat to humans and Wildlife
worldwide and we do need to start
investing in renewable sources i think
it's it's more of a shaker of the
systems already in place in the
mitigation systems and more money to be
put into research to be able to shake
shake this up so i completely agree with
what Leo's saying and and I think it's a
similar scenario with what's going on in
the church is obviously there's lots of
human wildlife conflict that arises when
wildlife comes into contact with areas
with expanding populations and whatnot
but I think what we do need to focus on
is dealing with that conflict and
legislation everything is in place so
that that we start with that but
obviously that has to be streamlined
yeah Leo I mean you've already hinted at
this a little bit that there is
obviously this raging debate and you get
people are pretty ideologically driven
when it comes to wind energy for and
against
is it however important the way we talk
about wind power that there's a there's
a total transparency and you've already
indicated this that yes sometimes there
are some downsides so we maybe haven't
even thought of all of them well I I
mean I to be honest I think the reverse
is true they resist a constant focus on
the downsides of wind energy you know
ten ten Commission our own piece of
research earlier and you know a few
weeks ago from Imperial College
analyzing media coverage of wind
generation in the UK over the last few
years and four out of five stories about
wind power 4 out of 5 editorials and
comment pieces are negative and focus on
the risks and you simply don't have this
level of scrutiny on the damage which is
being caused difference well yes so even
even articles on fracking tended to be
more positive than articles on onshore
wind generation which is really
extraordinary because you know the
government's own statistics show that
onshore wind generation is much much
more popular with the UK public than the
technologies day back like fracking and
nuclear so you know there is that there
is a huge mismatch between how wind
energy is presented and and the British
people's feelings about it actually and
the the level of opposition to win power
in the UK is remains very small it's
just that the people who really dislike
it are disproportionately influential
you know and i think i went out it's
very obviously with the people have got
to look at them a lot leo yes so you
know one of the things we campaign for a
tension is community energy college you
know community energy is the solution to
that problem leo thank you Adalia thanks
both very much indeed thanks a lot thank
you very much thank you